everyone might be feeling a little
stressed today oh why
i don't know jk hey jk there's a lot
going on
well i think ross and i have a solution
and if you're wondering what's on my
head it's my shower cap
recent studies have shown that baking
can actually help
relieve stress totally that's actually
right yes look at all of these martha
stewart los angeles times
and you know what i found an article
through our news division today
and it's usa today and it says how to
stay calm and distract yourself
on election day it talks about stress
baking but there's actually really great
links to movies and
tv shows and reading like very you know
we recommended the huff post
yes yesterday 15 things you can do in
voting lines i really like this article
for things you can do to distract
yourself today we gotta find some of you
to keep our minds busy and i'll tell you
cooking has always been one of those
things for me and baking now research
researchers say it can reduce stress so
are you ready to get in here drew
and make something here is our dough
really
you do this at home if you're feeling a
little anxious take it
out on this right yes take it out on
this bowl of pre-mixed
i just whoa okay smack that
oh yeah can i do that got a rolling pin
yeah you got it
okay if you like this drew we're gonna
roll out our dough like this okay
but there's something i'm supposed to be
actually doing but there's
i see that you you have a little pent up
anxiety right
okay are you going to spin it make a
piece like i wanted to like
do it one more time do it in see if i
can catch it okay ready yeah spin it to
me
[Music]
okay i want you to do this you're gonna
love this look we have pecans and
chocolate here right uh-huh
we have a mallet here okay so put those
down and then just
knock the heck out of them ready where
are my yours are right here here you go
all right get these out of here now
they're there here i'll start ready
one two three
i don't want to hear about the election
anymore
just work and kids in life and hail your
success and parents and family and all
of it
it's hard enough
was it good for you
[Laughter]
all right so then what we're gonna do
drew is i missed one
get it we're just gonna put a little
butter i mean does it really matter
there's cinnamon rolls but really it's
about hitting them
i like brushing it with butter yes you
put a little butter just
you know why not boil up
then we'll do a little cinnamon and
sugar on okay sometimes i literally
think of like my boss turning on
the show and being like what is going
on i know but see everyone
wishes they were here i'm telling you
[Laughter]
sorry you're kind of freaking me out i
know i can't help it
we just roll it up all right roll it up
oh we roll it yeah this is really easy
this is just hold on
now i'm going to channel my intramural
street from it's complicated please do
i've been waiting for you by the way
that's a great movie to watch today
the perfect movie to watch any nancy
meyers movie
sign me up watch baby boom oh i love
baby boom
country baby homemade in cleveland i
don't think so that's my favorite line
anyway drew roll it up okay now you're
just gonna cut them
and you guys it's kind of like pinocchio
like what what
enoki
so it's not gnocchi no but it's spelled
that way okay
sorry so um do you know this is pizza
dough so this isn't anything fancy you
can totally just get this and make it at
home
every like italian person probably is
watching just turn the channel i'm so
sorry oh stop it but you know what i
find that baking don't you think when
you can
you live in my head and just say oh stop
it to me all the time yeah i don't know
if i can afford it but i'll try
otherwise it's like oh
see this is so good for you i know do
you find it meditative to do this whole
process i
am really loving this yeah nancy meyers
baking
like distraction articles things to get
into
i forgot a step we were supposed to put
our stuff the nuts and
chocolates i got to tell you something
as much as i want to crush nuts
i don't want them in my cinnamon rolls
oh i like that you're
i love when people like it's like when
people put nuts and stuffing i'm like
what are you doing i think it's just
nuts
it is and don't put raisins and just
give me mirepoix
celery carrots onion maybe a little
crumbled sausage i could handle but
don't mess with a classic cinnamon rolls
i feel like are all about the cream
and the dough yeah well well i don't
mind a little chocolate in here but this
is the final result you guys
and the best part about this is once you
um go into the good place when you're
baking
you can um stress eat
is that good do you mind the nuts now no
no
i have to say you look like you're
handling this a lot better now
you know what what that's really good
well look this is the beauty shot ladies
and gentlemen this is what the end
result
will look like if you have somebody else
make it not either one of us
here's more you want more throw it at me
[Laughter]
you know i love you
go out and vote everybody
drew can i do it oh no
why oh just do it do it do it
[Music]
from afar here oh let's hit rolling pins
oh okay yeah this is fun too
yeah i hope you all have a friend that
you can do this with at home you guys
just get through today we're gonna be
okay
everybody um go to our website for this
[Music]
recipe
you